turn around always turn a negative
situation into a positive situation
michael jordan tuesday morning i woke up
at 11am and i felt terrible about it
talk about a late start to the day the
night before I was up reading about
Martin Luther King and just as I was
about to go to bed I find out that ootp
baseball was finally out it's my
favorite baseball computer game and I
had ordered this new release months ago
the company tease me with hints of the
features that were put in four months
and it was finally here so of course I
had to download it and start playing it
I then look up at my screen and notice
that it's 3am what just happened waking
up at eleven sucks for me I've usual
routine I go through and it threw me way
off I had just over four hours before i
had to go pick up my son from school I
felt incredibly guilty and unproductive
I hated that I wasted so much time and
now it was behind I almost felt like
giving up on the day because I had
little time left it was time for a
turnaround I remember watching a
presentation a few years ago about a guy
who tracked his happiness a few times
per day he just asked himself how happy
am I on a scale of one to ten right now
and he collected the data he compared
the numbers to the activities he was
doing so he could find out what made him
happy versus unhappy the only thing I
remember from the presentation was that
he was least happy when he felt
unproductive or stuck in a problem what
was really interesting was that he felt
most happy right after he was really
unhappy by doing the exact opposite
activity so for example if he was
unhappy because he was unproductive he
became very happy by being super
productive I needed my turn around
instead of feeling down all day I poured
myself in the writing my book I made
some serious progress and fix a few
sections that I wasn't quite happy with
after a few hours of work I had a real
sense of accomplishment it felt so good
I couldn't believe that only a few hours
ago I was so depressed life is going to
throw you lots of surprises it can be so
easy to get down on yourself when you
don't see results when you don't see
momentum happening when you feel
unproductive don't give up on the day
poor whatever remaining energy you have
into something that is important to you
it'll make you come alive and put you
right back in a positive mindset when
you feel down start your turn around
amazing things will happen believe